joins us now with more we have the house
investigation into whether the doj has
been weaponized uh I don't believe we
have equal justice or equal application
of our laws at this point in in our
country's history Senator tell us uh
what has alarmed you and why would you
ever think that mayor garland would
appoint a special counsel to investigate
himself
well Sean you're absolutely right that
there's a two-tiered system of justice
this Department of Justice this FBI is
the most politicized Department of
Justice and FBI we have ever seen you
mentioned the house the house is doing a
terrific job I had lunch today with
James Comer he and Jim Jordan together
are doing a fantastic job of trying to
hold the Biden Administration to account
the house is the only body of Congress
doing its job because Senate Democrats
don't want to know the truth they're not
interested but but here's where we are
on the facts we now have two credible
whistleblowers both IRS career employees
who've come forward at enormous risk to
their own careers to their own
livelihoods and they've reported on
corruption within the Department of
Justice specifically that Merrick
Garland and his political appointees
repeatedly interfered in the
investigation of Hunter Biden and
especially that what they did is they
protected the White House they protected
the big guy they said no questions about
the big guy you're not allowed to
investigate the big guy not only that
they allege that the Department of
Justice tipped off Hunter Biden's
lawyers before they executed a search
warrant before they tried to to to
question Hunter Biden repeatedly
they allege the senior officials at the
Department of Justice obstructed that
this investigation now we don't know if
these whistleblowers are telling the
truth
but if they are if they're telling the
truth their testimony is flatly
contradictory with what America Garland
has said under oath I question Merrick
Garland in front of the Senate Judiciary
Committee and he told the Judiciary
Committee under oath that that the U.S
attorney investigating Hunter Biden had
complete authority to investigate and
that there was Zero political
interference his statement is directly
contrary to what the Whistleblower said
the house needs to have a hearing they
need to have both whistleblowers under
oath they need to have David Weiss the
U.S attorney under oath and then you
have Merrick Garland the Attorney
General under oath somebody's lying and
if Garland's lying he committed lying
under oath to Congress which is a felony
and he committed obstruction of justice
which is a felony he obviously can't
investigate himself so Merrick Garland
should be recused from the entire matter
and the Department of Justice should
appoint a special counsel to determine
whether or not the Attorney General of
the United States
with the honor and integrity to do it
and I'd like to get to the bottom of the
1023 form but we're talking also about
six whistleblowers and my understanding
is that tomorrow John Solomon
investigative reporter editor-in-chief
of just thenews.com he will be on this
show he has a document in that document
it'll show the recommendation to in fact
indict Hunter Biden on tax charges
felony charges dealing with the years
that have now passed the statute of
limitations if that ends up being true
uh would that mean that Mr Weiss didn't
do his job
well it would and and what the IRS
whistleblowers also alleged is is is
that Mr Weiss tried to get the U.S
attorney in the central district of
California and the U.S attorney in the
District of Columbia to bring charges
against Hunter Biden for the most
serious tax offenses the cases had to be
brought in D.C and California because
that's where the crimes occurred and
what the IRS whistleblowers alleged is
those U.S attorneys refused to bring the
case and to be clear one of those U.S
attorneys was a was a political donor to
Joe Biden another of those U.S attorneys
was a political donor to Kamala Harris
and their allegations again are directly
contrary to what Merrick Garland has
said under oath and and this is
something I've talked about it at Great
length on my podcast verdict with Ted
Cruz you look at these whistleblowers
both of them are career IRS employees
one Gary shapley was a senior
supervisory agent with a lot of
experience he has no reason uh that's
evident on the record lie he doesn't
appear to be a republican the other
whistleblower he's self-described as a
gay Democrat with a man for a husband
there's no reason to think he's got an
ax to grind with Joe Biden and yet he's
got the courage to call this out we need
a special counsel because the Attorney
General is not above the law and neither
is Joe Biden Senator I hope you keep
your foot on the gas I agree completely
thank you so much we appreciate it
coming up hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else